hey everybody i'm ashley graham and this
is my glamour
beauty spy
[Music]
okay so this is how i get my ultimate
glow
it's on okay so first of all you have to
get the ashley graham centro pay
ultimate glow kit right here it's so fun
there's a mitt inside and there is your
mousse inside
so it's all about prep first and
foremost make sure you exfoliate in the
shower don't use an abrasive
soap then you're going to want to
moisturize your hands your feet
your elbows your knees and you're going
to want to have baby wipes um
waiting on the side because you're going
to wipe down the insides of your hand
shake it up a little bit give yourself a
little squirt
see how it just kind of like foams up so
basically how i would do it is i would
just kind of
start to move up it's okay so they will
clean that up
and you just kind of work your way up
and you see how it like just starts to
really rub
in and then you can take this knit and
really just rub it in and that's how you
basically put it on
all over your whole body and then the
parts that you can't actually
um reach you do
the face purity mist and so what i like
to do
is i like to spray the face purity most
after i put on my serums and my lotions
and my whole thing
and then i just
that's it for the face and then the back
like where you can't reach
you get all of that and then the hands
you do a little cloth
i like to wear the ultimate glow kit for
about three hours and then i take a
shower
then i do my face purity miss on my
hands my back
and my and my face because then it'll
it'll dry and you wake up and
everything's even
[Music]
okay so these are my these are my
absolute
favorite products that i swear by
every day and my favorite sunscreen is
the dermaphysiologique
um i like it because it's white it's
super protective but when it goes on
it's
super clear i've used this so much that
i
i just ordered some more but my dentist
actually made
um this amazing toothpaste it's coconut
oil based
and it's called intelliwhite her name's
dr jablo
it's it's truly phenomenal and it makes
my breath
smell really good then i'm all about a
highlighter because on top of my
ultimate glow kit i have
to also use a little highlighter it's
illuminator it's the skin lights from
revlon
i put this all over my skin and then i
put my foundation on
i can also put this all over my chest my
shoulders i love it
it's a glow for all day at night mario
badescu
this is my favorite drying lotion for
acne i feel like now with the mask
let's get it about sit all up and down
my cheeks i've never has before
thank you masks hopefully it's over soon
but in the meantime marvel desc
this is a must must must
i use this every single night before i
go to bed um
it is just phenomenal um when it comes
to keeping up my tan
and i feel like i don't really use
foundation as much
when i'm actually staying up on my face
purity mist
a new hair product that i started doing
is called
five bryo geo it's new i don't know how
to say it but
this helps really define my curls and i
just put a little bit in when it's wet i
let it air dry but i
also use it in isaac's hair because he
has the same kind of hair texture as me
love this stuff and it smells like
really good too
okay so i feel like the best beauty hack
i've ever figured out
is to use an eyebrow pencil as a lip
liner
and my favorite is from revlon it's
called brown
and it's it's so good as a lip liner you
just kind of have to smudge it around a
little bit
oh a hot hair must have for me
postpartum life where all my hairline
fell out was definitely the caristas
serum it really helped um i'm still on a
hair journey because it's all growing
back but it's growing back and that's
the most important thing
daily must use ritual is definitely
serums and spf every day all day
my recipe for achieving skin glow is all
about santropay
vitamin c anything that has to do with
serums and
moisturizer glow glow glow favorite
wellness ritual
has to be prayer time and i think that
for me
everybody has something different they
meditate they work out they
just do quiet time for me it's about
prayer it's about speaking out loud
and it's something that i can do for
myself every day even if it's just five
minutes
do i suffer from insecurities i feel
like everybody does
we live in a world where we're like you
know being thrown
um who we should be and what we should
be saying to ourselves and
how we should be acting but i think the
way to combat that is through true
affirmations
and speaking well over yourself and
knowing what your mantras are and your
um and your your mantras for the day for
the week and everything
it's always changing and evolving around
you biggest beauty indulgence has to be
my facials from my
favorite facialist in new york mozilla
shimon she is
i mean i go in i look a mess i come out
i'm glowing i don't know how she does it
what she does but it takes an hour and a
half and i'm always so grateful
[Laughter]
biggest beauty thrill is definitely
beautiful is an aquaphor i use it on my
elbows my heels my lips
i think it's so multi-purposeful and
they even make it for babies so isaac
loves it too
right now it's anything but from byredo
i love
all the little mini travel sizes that
they have i throw one in my travel bag
in my purse i have one of my
vanity i mean i just love to have
different scents kind of always around
me
all right so that was my glamour beauty
spy i hope you guys enjoyed and i'm
curious
what are your glamour beauty spies
anyways
have fun take care thanks for joining